but we gotta we gotta jump to the story
about the republican party we got this
from breitbart exclusive tool to enforce
orwellian rules 80 house republicans
help pass bill to fund federal
vaccination database
according to the bill also called h.r
550 the government would provide 400
million in taxpayer dollars to fund
immunization system data monetization
and expansion a system otherwise defined
as a confidential population-based
computerized database that records
immunization doses administered by any
healthcare provided to persons within
the geographic area covered by that
database i want to point out it's called
the immunization infrastructure the
covet vaccine does not immunize you okay
this is very very important distinction
you will not be immune okay the youtube
rules are very clear on this one okay
the covet vaccine reduces the likelihood
you'll get it reduces the severity and
uh and if you do get it you know
hospitalization all that is reduced as
well there have been some graphs about
it but it's important because they're
calling it the immunization
infrastructure modernization act and i
think it's important the new york daily
news reported on lebron james getting
coveted and it said not even the king is
immune to kovid and i'm like and he's
fully vaxxed
i think this is the narrative here that
the vaccine is not immunization it is
vaccination and now i guess the
definition has changed to mean it
reduces your likelihood of catching and
having a severe case
so uh just one final thought is to move
into this we had 80 republicans sign on
board with this i don't believe that a
red wave is going to save americans
freedom yeah absolutely not i mean we've
been talking about this for a while be
prepared to be disappointed by the
people who are going to be the fall guys
it's it's just like wrestling they're
going to come in they're going to be you
know they're pretending to be the bad
guys now they're going to be the popular
guys but it's all a show it's all
scripted in so many different ways dan
crenshaw i heard also voted for this and
to see 80 house republicans vote for
federal vaccine registry what do you
think registration will lead to i mean
it's common sense it's what's happening
in germany it's what's happening in
australia it's what's happening in
israel it's what's happening in the
united kingdom they need a database of
everyone complying because now they know
who's playing ball and who's not it's no
longer going to be the paper that's your
vaccine proof it's going to be a federal
digital track tracing database system
which again will be integrated into the
social credit score which we've been
warning about from the very beginning of
this but it said it was confidential
they're saying
do you think a government federal
registry
how could anything go wrong
consolidating data like that
confidential means they get to read
through your private and sort of their
friends this is at the same time as the
federal government uh biden's um
kovidzar literally was on the national
media today saying that everything's on
the table to implement a domestic
vaccine passport when it comes to
interstate travel so this is literally
what the there's politicians there's
ruling elites in the united states that
are seething that are waiting to
implement what australia and what
germany have already implemented they
are waiting to implement this and it's
terrifying the cdc just gave themselves
new surveillance powers in order to
track this new variant who who allowed
them to to have surveillance powers they
did it themselves they're acting more
and more like just a totally runaway
undemocratic unfree government that
thinks they could impose their will onto
anyone when they want and that's
absolutely crazy and dangerous so the
founding fathers right
they're probably like sitting around in
ben franklin's living room they smoked a
lot so they're probably stoned or
probably on opium or something and then
jefferson's like dude
what if like we make a government
and it goes nuts and then ben was like
whoa
and then tom's like yo
we should give everyone the right to
keep and bear arms and then was like ben
was like dude dude we don't give it man
god gives it he's like yo yo yo right he
gives all this that might be
the best description i've ever heard
were probably drinking you know it was
probably at a pub and they were
underground and they were like have you
ever looked back and see what they they
drove what they drank at some of these
continental congress meetings what was
it insane amounts of alcohol
i i wrote something on it once years ago
i'm like because you will not believe
how much alcohol they consumed i didn't
believe it well they needed to because a
lot of the water wasn't safe for them to
drink so a lot of them drank beer
so they still have that big of water
issues in in 1770 it was easier for them
to make beer than to sometimes even
yeah so so you have all these dudes they
meet up together and they're all sitting
there and you know thomas jefferson and
john hancock and they're just like i i
we we can't go to war i mean i mean i
understand we're going to keep
petitioning the king it's like all right
a round of drinks on me but let's keep
talking and then by you know two hours
go by i would declare independence
standing on tables everybody gets guns
and they're like yeah and they're
fighting
i can honestly say this doesn't scare me
as much because
they got their fingers in everything and
and partly i count on the incompetence
of government like they're going to
collect a bunch of data it's going to
sit there um i i don't think the good
thing is our system is built to
withstand this unlike germany and
austria and australia everyone else i i
i get i'm not saying it's not a threat
it is a threat it's not going to happen
here and i'm i'm not saying that to make
people relax
we got to take it seriously but but i i
really believe
our our system is going to withstand
this there's not the political will in
any
let's face it the biden administration
is floundering do they really want to
pick this battle now say that you can't
you can't travel at all like they're
terrified that the economy no they're
not though if you look doing some some
stuff internationally that they're doing
i oppose all of it don't get me wrong i
i think they're terrified i i don't
think they're stupid enough to do to to
go down this road if at the beginning of
covid right if someone sat you down and
said everything's going to happen the
way it did would you believe them before
covet would with how far the government
has already intervened in our lives with
how much they have already taken from us
but how much they already locked this
down which how much they destroy this
boosters were a conspiracy theory yeah
no if someone if someone sat you down
before covenant began and said the
government's going to be disinvolved in
your life would you believe them before
kobe i i think i would believe what
happened in the united states i'd be
less inclined to believe what we're
seeing in australia
and some of those things um and
yeah i mean that that's my answer i i
would be shocked there there is the
potential for danger here we should
oppose it we should get angry about it
um but i i think
i think our system is going to prevail
in this case i think we're going to put
the kibosh on this it's not going to go
very far tsa extends mass mandate for
domestic flights over omicron
coronavirus variant through mid-march so
that's public transportation domestic
flights ships taxis trains
and we've already heard from fauci that
they're adding new requirements you need
a negative test before boarding an
international flight and after you get
here you got to quarantine so they are
slowly pushing this forward but look any
smart desperate knows you can't come out
and say
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna lock
you in your homes and weld your doors
shut that wouldn't work people would be
like screw off but after two years i
think it's fair to say we are in the rat
hope experiment are you familiar with it
i don't think i am dude puts rats in
these tubes full of water and they
struggle after 15 minutes they give up
and they drown and die
he puts another group of rats in there
they struggle right as they're giving up
he takes them out dries them off lets
them chill picks them up puts them back
in the second time they go in they swim
for 60 hours believing if i just keep
swimming eventually the hand will save
me again
so we go under this lockdown for about a
year and a few months and then they let
it all open everyone's like oh thank
heavens we're getting back to normal and
the economy should be coming back it's
not and then all of a sudden they say oh
no
a new variant
now we've got to start implementing
these lockdowns and they're not going to
do it instantly because people would
lose it but i say give it a few months
especially with the midterms coming up
they're going to exploit this crisis and
then they're going to lock us down
harder than we've seen i could be wrong
about it i don't know i'll say just you
know i'll go back to my home state i
live in minnesota twin cities we're not
we're not you know i won't say we're a
blue state but we're certainly a purple
state you know governor tim walls was
recently like you know
getting questions like why aren't you
going under an emergency lockdown and
and
he gave an answer that was incredibly
honest like he didn't you know he he
really implied that that politics had
something to do with it now he also said
there's no evidence that says this would
be you know effective another emergency
order um i i think you know above all
else you know politics is is staying
elected and i think people know that
americans are are kind of fed up with
these policies um and yeah like the feds
have some power as far as like what they
can monitor
you know vaccines in international
travel and things um
i just partly i'm trying to be
optimistic here i don't want to be too
doom and gloom you know like we're not
australia yet and i i don't think we're
going to be because um
americans have wised up a lot and we
have guns it makes a big difference in
the last 18 months i think americans
have kind of awoken
i hate to say that
you are right you are right i actually
uh i recorded a segment on this earlier
that uh democrat pollsters are basically
sending you know red flags up saying
we're gonna lose in 2022 and the reason
is the economy is the most important
issue number one and democrats aren't
talking about it
the the lockdowns seriously impact the
economy but in virginia one pollster
said
it wasn't critical race theory certainly
that had some of some
some of an impact but it was the coveted
restrictions on schools parents were
already struggling due to the
lockdowns now their kids are back at
home and they're trying to figure out
nannies or who's going to watch the kids
and they got really angry about it so
because of their their push towards this
is why i think there's a good
possibility they might not because they
know if they do this the american people
are i've already said no way
i think they're still going to maintain
this path because of social media
pressures and so long as republicans
don't do anything stupid like voting on
you know a bill to create a vaccine
database which they did and they
shouldn't be supporting that it's
ridiculous and anybody that did like you
know if i was
one of their constituents i'd be writing
them a letter but that's what they're
doing they don't care about the letters
they care about the big multinational
corporations that really call the shots
here and they will appease them they
will bow down they will get on their
knees i have no hope for the republicans
when they take over i have no hope in
den crenshaw mitt romney lis chaney and
the party of roll over let's let our
soft bellies be shown to the globalists
as of course we sell out our
constituents as the hope that we're
going to be something better when we're
just going to be the same thing but a
different color behind it i'm so sick of
it we should be appalled that the u.s
government shut down small businesses
while allowing walmart costco and all
these other big box stores amazon to do
whatever they wanted to they destroyed
and have created the largest transfer of
wealth in recorded human history robbing
poor people blind enriching the
billionaire class and if we think
they're not capable of doing what
australia is doing to its people i think
we're not paying attention i think we're
at a at a moment where there are they
are itching for a new tragedy to exploit
and they will use anything manufacture
or anything or even do anything to
create this tragedy at this particular
moment in order to get their way i can
like i echo most of that now but here's
what i will say like i don't trust
you know a republican any more than a
democrat for the most part at the same
time i as a libertarian like we gridlock
is good we want gridlock gridlock if you
look at you know historically at
spending and other metrics we can use
you know when when there's gridlock in
congress well a lot
less bad stuff happened but it's not
gridlocked the republicans were on board
with every agenda pushed against the
american people especially when kovit
came they were like yes dr fauci is
great whatever dr fauci wants dr fauci
gets 14 days to slow the spread great
idea and republicans didn't even bat an
eye didn't give a damn about their
constituents their people they said back
the blue support police officers as they
bust down your door and shut down your
business that's ridiculous and for
people to still believe that they're
going to change anything i think it's
naive in my personal opinion but i may
be i may be two black people no i i hey
there there's reason for cynicism and
and i don't you're not wrong that the
gop what did they do for us in 2020 um
not not a heck of a lot um so so i i
hear where you're coming from but
i have no you know misconceptions um
next year if if republicans take the
house if they take the senate is
everything going to change well well no
but gridlock is good if there is a
primary red wave and everybody who
watches this goes and tells 10 of their
friends and family to vote in the
primaries
then you will get something special come
november because all of a sudden you're
gonna have a whole bunch of you know
populists being like all that
establishment crap is out thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you